foreign
questioned one of the most enjoyable
parts of your show is listening to your
personal journey and your interviewees
journeys of transcendence any recent
spiritual shifts that you would not mind
sharing I don't mind sharing I was
actually recently in the mountains of
New Mexico
and
experienced some of the most profound
and extreme time dilation I have I've
ever felt certainly in a sober state
with a friend of mine and so we were we
were hiking at altitude for on and off
for several days and
by say day three thinking back to the
morning of even day two or day one felt
like looking back to three weeks or four
weeks prior so being in nature
I think partially contributing to that
was the fact that we changed locations
so many times and that the Topography of
the land changed so many times so it
could as as well have been four or five
different countries we visited given how
different the Landscapes were and the
wildlife and so on
but that time dilation I think
highlights something for me at least
which is
there are different ways to extend or
better set I think expand life to live
in an expansive State more often and
many of the let's just call them
post-economic extremely wealthy
successful in financial terms Founders
and CEOs and so on I know want to extend
health span which I think is a very
worthwhile objective looking at science
and technology for
extending healthy years right
however you can live a long time but
almost never be present I'm not saying
that's true for these people but I I
know people who live a long time and
they're so preoccupied about the past or
the future or the news or the politician
on TV or whatever that they have a lot
of time contraction time passes very
quickly for them so what if you could
design a life and pre-schedule
experiences such that you have the type
of time dilation I'm talking about where
let's just say even twice a year you
have two trips each week long and each
of those one-week trips actually feels
like three months well
have you then in that case effectively
added let's just say each one feels like
three months okay have you added six
months to each year by doing that in
terms of your experiential lifespan
if so that's very interesting and so now
you're you're living let's just call it
50 longer in your remaining years so
does that have the net net positive or
even a greater benefit than simply
extending your biological lifespan by
that period of time I don't know I do
think that's a I don't think I know
that's a question that's been on my mind
and we can certainly pursue both but one
is available here and now and the others
are more so a scientific road map with
possibilities but I think this type of
time dilation through
very deliberately designed experience
and immersion is very
seductive and rewarding